so I think there's like several levels
of understanding a singers JavaScript
there is you know a level one is I don't
which is like a place right like I start
as a ruby developer when I switch to
like JavaScript like I just literally
didn't know why that variable was
undefined I literally just called
beforehand cuz I didn't get how many if
it worked then there's like level two
which is I think where a lot of us live
which is I don't really understand how
it works but if I know I thought I use
dot bind to this and throw everything in
that callback everything's fine right
and I lived there for a really long time
and then I got this like unpaid gig
where I had to write documentation for
Mozilla and I had to like actually
understand how it worked I like figure
it out like what the browser was doing
it of the hood and once I got there then
like everything became a little clearer
so my job in the next 25 minutes is to
kind of compress that down and get try
especially I can to get you all the way
there you ready all right so my name is
Steve which I feel like we covered so I
don't really need to go into that I live
in Colorado and I don't know how to ski
those are the important details there I
work at place called Sun grid if you've
ever taken an uber or late night bid on
something on eBay and got an email about
it we sent you that email
along with us several other billion
emails every day I actually work on a
WYSIWYG HTML editor that makes HTML
email so like Ben's talked about 1999
I lived there asking me ask me about
Outlook later
I am perpetually working on a book an
electron I finished writing in October
and then in May electron two came out so
I updated it and then they announced the
electron 3 beta so it's just never going
to be done
so yeah cool when I kind of tweeted
earlier today I like those cool signs
outside and my friend Brian Sinclair
said that I should rename the talk
asynchronous JavaScript actually
explained or Ajax was short I told him I
was gonna use in this talk and this is
what he said
so the important note here is that you
should outsource your conference jokes
to your friends and then everyone thinks
you're funny when really you just have
funny friends so we're going to talk
about a little bit with about our
relationship with asynchronous code I
guess that starts out with like what
does asynchronous really mean and we're
gonna find out the only way that you can
truly learn about anything which is to
torture some metaphors so we're gonna
run some errands and we're gonna learn
about synchronous code in the process
maybe so two things I need to do I need
to pick up a prescription from the
pharmacy and I need to go to Safeway and
that's like I don't wear glasses but
that's the best I could do so step one
if I was doing this synchronously I
would take my prescription
I'd go stand there and wait in line as
somebody wanted to argue with the
pharmacist about what their insurance
didn't did not cover as if that was
gonna help anything and then finally I
would pick up my prescription and I
would go along my merry way I finished
one task and I'd go on and I'd go down
to Safeway do y'all have Safeway in
Omaha what's the grocery store around
here
what's that cool I didn't I I didn't
have a safe way to move to Colorado so
that's a new thing for me and I can go I
give them some money and in exchange I
get some carrots or a carrot and I move
along my it's just expensive these days
life is really hard I go ahead and now I
want to run them asynchronously so what
is the kind of difference they're the
whole thing of what they synchronous
stuff is like a non-blocking thing I
almost liberated a balloon there where I
can show up again and I'll drop off my
prescription and then while they're
handling all that were prescription then
I will go down and I'll go shopping I
will shoplift a carrot I got 25 minutes
I can't do every animation every time
everyone and that eventually I'll go
ahead and pick up my prescription
and I'm good to go so now it's a
synchrony is almost a form of
concurrency right I can kind of do two
things at once while I'm waiting for one
other thing and go do something else
right there are some like caches here
which is that functions in JavaScript
run to completion so again let's go back
to our metaphor I go ahead I drop off my
prescription head on over to Safeway and
I flash them some money I get my carrot
and while I'm shopping my prescription
is ready now I can't just like leave the
grocery store with this carrot because
that is illegal right they will
prosecute me they have signs that say
this I can't stop what I'm doing I have
to finish what I'm doing a Safeway you
know flash some money received my carrot
and then I can go ahead and I can pick
up my prescription right so we have to
finish what we're doing in JavaScript so
just because this is actually this is
the holy javascript a single-threaded
kind of thing which is half true but it
actually solves a lot of concurrency
problems where like you're gonna finish
the thing you're doing so if new
information comes in or something else
happens it can't really change the state
of what you're currently working on
which solves the whole series of
problems for us and it's great cool all
right so we've got some metaphors in
place what does that run to completion
look like what does it mean to run to
completion really means three things one
is that an error is thrown and not
caught that will like blow everything up
and you're done
two is that you return from the function
which is you complete it and three is
there's no more code in the function
right and so in JavaScript that returns
undefined and other languages it might
return the last thing so on and so forth
all right so then the next question is
why do we have
why is asynchrony important why is
non-blocking important with building
user interfaces most frameworks of
building user interfaces have some idea
of a synchrony because it's important if
you're going to have a user interface
multiple things are probably going on so
here's an example we've got a little
this little box that I made that's very
cool I'm selecting some text if I hover
over the buttons I'll get some CSS hover
events everything's really great I hit
that start blocking button and you'll
notice that my animation stopped all my
CSS transitions stopped I can't select
any text like game over
how did he block the browser this is how
I block the browser yeah open source
I'll put it on NPM later you can all
install it
it'll be great I pretty sure it's secure
cool all right so now we have like some
of the basics of why it's important in
what it means how does it actually work
so asynchronous JavaScript is based on
events the same events if you've you
know done any jQuery or just vanilla
JavaScript with the Dom that same idea
of events that is for every like promise
library you've ever used or observables
or whatever under the hood there's
probably an event happening right a lot
of times we use abstractions to hide a
lot of that we don't have to deal with
it but there it is under the hood that's
kind of a level that we're going to talk
about today all this stuff happens under
the hood because all the fanciest
asynchrony library that you've ever used
it's still based on a few simple core
language features so we'll kind of we're
gonna explore those today so all right
how does synchronous code work right
it's kind of it's like a Tarantino movie
we're like jumping back and forth it's
okay it's intentional so in you know
programming we have this thing called
the call stack right and that's keeping
track where we are in the execution of
our program so here's my here's my
program I have an array of possessions I
have a life savings it's 25 25 what I
don't know and but that's it I'm a
millennial that's all I have and I got
two things I'm going to do is I'm gonna
go grocery shopping and I'm gonna buy
some when I'm grocery shopping I'm gonna
buy some vegan ham so that like we'll
have those different functions that
would run if I have enough life savings
whatever unit that is I will purchase
some vegan ham if not I will throw an
error saying I don't have enough money
and then we will execute the go grocery
shopping function which will execute the
by beak and hand function and so on and
so forth so what does that look like in
the call stack we kind of start the
program at the top level okay we
declared a bunch of functions but the
first function that we execute is go
grocery shopping cool that immediately
calls buy vegan ham we run through that
you know I decrement my life savings I
push vegan ham into my
array of possessions who amongst us
hasn't done that and that finishes up
the vegan ham function which then brings
us to the end of the go grocery shopping
function which like finishes up my
program now if it's in the browser it's
just gonna chill out and wait for other
events if it's a node program it would
like we'd be done we'd be kicked back
out to bash need alright let's just go a
little bit I'm also gonna buy some
organic almond milk which is very
expensive it is 20 of whatever which is
gonna cause a problem when I to go to
pick up my vegan ham because I'm not
gonna have enough life savings anymore
for this right so this is gonna be a
little bit different so we'll run
through this code again the first coat
the first piece of code that we actually
excuse go grocery shopping which then
calls the buy organic almond milk
function neat that executes just fine we
run that to completion cool now we're
going to go grocery shopping oh now
we're going to the next function which
is buy the vegan ham things are gonna be
really good here
that's gonna blow up that's right I use
that thing in keynote and I'm not even
ashamed of myself
and it's going to blow up the entire
call stack you're like this is
interesting
you've seen the call stack before it's
just like you don't have like fond and
warm fuzzy feelings about it cuz this is
usually the context in which you see the
call stack is when something has blown
up right they'll show you everything
that happened between where that initial
fire started and all the ways that
escalated up cool alright that's
synchronous code how does asynchronous
stuff work so the a singer stuff goes on
this thing called the event queue which
we kind of check repeatedly with the
event loop like remember I said when
you're in the browser like the page
doesn't close and your JavaScript stops
running right that would be bad I mean
you could probably do that it'd be kind
of cool but it's probably bad it kind of
triggers don't wait for like click
events or all sorts of other events that
could happen so we've got this cue with
the call stack it is first in lat
first-in first-out right this is
whatever I'm not I'm not live computer
science in terms you all right like we
started we you know we started from the
the top thing and work our way down this
one we will take whatever came first
like a normal line and we'll
ahead we'll handle the first one then
the second one and then finally the
third one cool where it gets a little
more interesting is how these two
interact which is we can only check the
event queue with the event loop
whenever the call stack is clear so
anything that's in the queue will wait
until the call stack is clear if it's
clear it can kind of move over because
we keep checking the queue whenever the
call stack is emptied more stuff comes
along if it's empty just go handle it in
the order that it was received all right
neat so I lied to you at the beginning
of this talk which is always fun to open
with lies it's a way to build trust and
friendship amongst your audience there's
no such thing as asynchronous JavaScript
which is also a lie for the first 20
years of JavaScript there was no such
like there was no mention of asynchrony
in the JavaScript spec javascript was
asynchronous as Ruby and Python and all
the other languages where you didn't
have to deal with asynchronous code
right in the es2015 spec there's this
little thing about a job SKU that has to
do with promises but let's just like
live like in a world where the specs
still doesn't say anything about
asynchronous code because like generally
speaking like we had promised polyfills
before that was in there let's just make
that little detail doesn't exist and
just go with the idea that there's no
such thing as a synchronous JavaScript
you're like how am I gonna accidentally
accidentally understand the thing that
doesn't exist I don't know so most of
the things we think about is
asynchronous actually comes from the
environment right what is the
environment well it's like whatever
browser you're running in or node in
this case so the lack of a browser but
like v8 in that case and in the widow
object you've got like the whole dom
which is separate from javascript right
there's a set of API is that you can use
and you call it with JavaScript methods
but it's separate from the JavaScript
programming language itself and then we
have this other thing called the
behavior object model or the bomb which
is all the things that we think are part
of the JavaScript language but if you
read the ACMA scripts spec aren't in
there at all and so it's set timeout set
interval it's set interval XML HTTP
request fetch requestanimationframe all
those very like browser specific ones
some of those reported over to node not
all of them but they're not necessarily
part of the
script language and most of them are
implemented in C or C++ if you just do
like set timeout in chrome dev tools
it'll just be like native code it won't
show you the function definition like a
would for a function you wrote because
it's actually not in JavaScript right so
there's there's no such thing as
asynchronous JavaScript but like let's
just ignore that so one example I like
of asynchronous call is set timeout
everyone's like friend which will in
this case it takes a function that you
want to call and then some amount of
time that you want to wait before that
function is called and it's very like I
think a common mistake is that a lot of
people think that this will execute in
500 milliseconds that's not true it will
be added to the event queue in 500
milliseconds right which if there's
stuff in a call stack it's gonna sit
there and wait until that's clear right
we just we saw that earlier so it's like
at least 500 milliseconds that's why if
you're trying to do like smooth
animations set timeout or set interval
and not your friend
stuff like requestanimationframe is
probably a better bet because this is at
least 500 milliseconds so if you're
trying to get like buttery smooth stuff
that's not gonna work so here we are we
have stuff in here we have to throw a
set timeout that's gonna get who's gonna
wait for that hundred milliseconds and
then our buddy's gonna sneak in that
function that has that like infinite
loop of while true it's gonna sneak in
there which is yeah after like a
thousand milliseconds that's gonna be
added to the event queue and never
called ever right so you'd be like hey
one if you want to try this at home a
really great example of a blocking
function one of the last like true
blocking functions in JavaScript that
you can use is alert so you can do
something where it like sets the timeout
and then immediately calls an alert for
light you say set timeout like one one
second later you know you then you fire
an alert and then go like make a
sandwich or something right it will
block that code until you dismiss that
alert and then everything on the event
queue will begin to get cleared out so
it's a really great way to highlight
visualize that and you might be like
neat you made that like I don't have
infinite loops in my code yes what you
think I don't have infinite loops that I
know of in my code is usually what that
means but there's still cases where
it doesn't have to be infinite to be
problematic so if you have any kind of
expensive test we've all seen that thing
in like Chrome or Firefox there's like
this script is taking longer than
expected do you want to kill it or keep
waiting right that is something that has
taken too long and somebody wrote that
line of code me but like there are ways
that you can actually take advantage of
the event queue in the event loop to
make this easier so you can use timers
or you can how to make your pages more
responsive with one weird trick so all
right here's a contrived example we have
some expensive batch tasks that's gonna
iterate through 10,000 a million records
and do something expensive each one it
could even just be updating the Dom
right so what we could do is we could
iterate through this really really large
array and do stuff but that's going
again like block up the works
so like we'll keep going in there
they'll stack up and stuff will end up
in the queue and never really like get
executed right he'll just wait a click
events also they'll basically have the
same effect of when we saw the animation
stop and the CSS hover stop it's not
great right what we could do is we could
go ahead and like basically take
advantage of the event queue to split it
up which is like we're going to put each
individual one on the event queue which
means stuff like click events and also
to hover away other events can kind of
get in the middle of that line so we can
have a quick event some something
expensive can get in there and animation
can happen we can start to interleave
stuff that the user did with stuff that
are really expensive function is doing
right and yes you could also like pull
it off to a web work into a and maybe
just do it a server-side right yeah all
is it possible but this is like you know
one that I could fit on slides that's
great so now it'll go through all those
things neat all right now the most
common way that we're going to use
asynchronous JavaScript is likely that
we are going to make an AJAX request
right and you have probably never
written this and as I go through this
code you'll see why because it's
terrible and why would you do this but
the way it works is you make a new
xmlhttprequest you have a load event you
have an error event and then you open it
with the method and the endpoint and
then you send it and then that load
event will trigger or the error event
depend
how this goes right so that's how just
vanilla xmlhttprequest works most of us
use something like X cos or jQuery
dollar sign at Ajax something else along
these lines but out of the hood that is
the kind of like native browser
implementation so one pattern for doing
this is the callback pattern right and
callbacks aren't anything special it's
the nice part about first-class
functions in JavaScript is that
functions could be passed as arguments
to other functions exhibit joke cool and
so here's an example we can pass in a
function as an argument and then we can
call it inside of that function like
this is a silly example of a callback
pattern so let's take that XML from
before and we're going to refactor it
we're like I took out error we'll just
we'll do what that separately so what
are the kind of pieces that can change
here well the callback when it loads
write the method and the end point so we
take all those and we go ahead and we
just make a new function where we're
going to pass those in do a little
copy/paste action because like that's
how you write code and you just take the
parts they're gonna change and replace
them with the arguments that pass in
right now we can go from this big mess
of code to this you want to use it again
you don't have to write that code all
over again you just use your new
callback pattern right you've
effectively invented a very bad version
of dollar-sign Ajax in jQuery we have no
we have no error handling in that so we
need an alternative approach now jQuery
does it differently than no did it right
and we can kind of look at some of those
right which is we had that load but what
about when things go wrong so we can we
in have the callback there if if an if
we have like let's say greater than the
400 we'd say like hey this didn't go
well otherwise we're gonna do the right
thing so we'll have the error callback
oops
well have the error callback and the
regular callback and we'll be able to
like have both right node handled this a
little bit differently so here this is
the jQuery model will pass in hey here's
a callback if things go well here's a
callback of things go poorly write the
node way of handling this is to go ahead
and have one callback where the first
argument always be an error the second
argument will be or further arguments
are the good stuff right and then going
ahead if things go poorly we pass the
error and it's the first argument if
things go well it passed the right stuff
and it's the second argument so then we
do something like this to have our error
and good state cool
callbacks have problems you can usually
only do one thing with that date like
one step function is over once it's run
to completion you don't have any of
those variables anymore they're now out
of scope you can't really store the
results anywhere because of that like
you can get really creative what the
window object please don't you have to
be creative with event at hand with
error handling we saw that and basically
it's like with that it's like you're
putting some function that you wrote
onto the event queue and saying hey
whenever that comes back here's a
function go call it if it's something
like billing or something like that you
don't know that somebody else who have
you handed that function to isn't gonna
call it like six times right you've
given that function away it's outside of
your hands you've given it to the event
queue and you hope for the best
and then like there's always that like
pyramid of doom right if you need to
like go ahead and like okay we need that
day they'll call the second one to call
the third one right and so this is like
I want to get all of the members from
all the organizations that I'm in on
github like you get that like pyramid of
doom as your code gets just scooching
further and further to the right and now
you have this moment of the scroll
horizontally in your text editor you
know something has gone terribly wrong
cool like I could get like that code
that should show you could get worse
that's fine name like the fellow members
of one organization if I wanted to find
all the members from all the
organizations this you can just see that
this pyramid just gets worse and worse
and worse so in like more and more cases
there's libraries like the async library
it's velbon MPLS right but there's
probably of other tools in language now
one of this just promises and so jQuery
supports promises where you can actually
just take make an asynchronous request
and you can store it into a variable and
promises like jQuery aren't technically
promises they are deferred because they
don't follow the promise spec all right
you just call them all Venables if you
want to seem cool we're just going to
use the promise the word promise is a
generic thing today so you can say hey I
basically you back an IOU when you
called asynchronous request right it's
like yeah I'm gonna hit that endpoint
I owe you there's eventually I'm gonna
have something back from the server or
an error you're like cool
when that comes back then go do this
other thing right and whatever that
payload of data is will get passed into
that function that you pass in and
what's cool is that it solves a lot of
the problems of course we can do
multiple things over and over and over
again and you can also do cool stuff
like chaining promises alright so here
we can have the promise that resolved
just immediately creates a promise that
has resolved right so this will resolve
with two in that data so you can be like
okay cool console.log it or you can add
one and that will return a new promise
every then returns a new promise with
the return value of the previous
function right so here we'll have that
too then we'll add one now it's three x
two it's six second taking the second
powers 36 so on and so forth right you
can take that original one you can store
it and have it back again as a two you
do a lot of really interesting because
instead of giving away that function
where you don't have a control anymore
you actually are in control you have it
all and you on your side of the equation
and you can do interesting stuff with it
as you need to all right and promises
like love them or hate them are also
interesting because a lot of other
really cool stuff in the language like
observables and async await involves
promises as well under the hood right so
you could be even be using promises in
cases that you don't know you're using
promises all right cool so here you've
just needed more practical example
here's our Dallas injection before we
can have a function called render post
which will receive a post and like make
some markup for us and then we can every
time we have the request we can map it
through that and we get much cleaner
code we're like avoiding that like
pyramid of Doom that we had before which
is very cool so then we can like go
ahead and like do something like add
them to the page there is a problem
though which is we do need to solve for
that error stage right here we'll throw
a new error in the middle that's not
great because the promise is counted as
rejected so we do in that case is that
we catch errors at the very end if you
don't catch them at the very end then
like other stuff can go wrong so you
usually keep your catch if any promise
along that entire chain rejects you can
handle it somewhere along with you oh
sorry we couldn't get your stuff or
whatever most of time we're consuming
promises sometimes we have to make them
if you have yeah that's
problematic if you have to make them
right you just use the new promise
constructor which takes a function which
passes in resolved and reject which are
also functions and basically if good
things happen you call resolve with it
whatever that data was passed the good
things in they'll get past the dot then
if bad things happen then you'll go
ahead and reject and everything will
work along those ways so let's go ahead
and refactor that callback pattern real
fast all right so this is the callback 1
we're simply going to return a new
promise where we'll have the resolving
the reject well can I take that code
where it cut and paste it right and now
instead of calling the callback where
you get rid of that and we will reject
in the case that it didn't go well and
we will resolve it in the case that it
did right and there we took a callback
pattern I'll show it to you again
we'll take that callback pattern we
turned it into a promise pattern that's
it right that's all the black magic of
like making promises which in listen we
could library you don't have to usually
you consume promises like 99% of the
time but occasionally if you don't have
it's like oh this is giving me callbacks
I don't like callbacks cuz I watch the
talk and he said they're problematic and
now I use promises you can actually just
wrap anything in a promise as well
there's some cool things like promised
at all which will basically take an
array of promises and if they all r is a
like to now you can set a whole
battalion of network requests and if
they all come back then you can go to a
thing
there's promised outrace which I have
never actually found a reason to use
sorry and that will actually come back
with the first one right so the first
promise that resolves you'll get that
one I leave it as an exercise of the
razor reader so promises always run to
completion that was a lie also well
you'll knows have an asterisks asterisks
will create you a generator function and
generator functions can actually kick
back control a number of times this
yield instead of return every time we
yield we go back to the scope that
called it we couldn't go back in the
call stack in that case so yield one two
three I can you know make a new
generator and I can say dot next the
first time I'll get one the second time
I'll get two 13:03 eventually the
function is actually to completion and
so we can kind of like leave a function
and come back in which it's not kind of
neat the really interesting part which
again is super confusing to see on a
slide so I apologize to these slides in
advance I'm going somewhere
that I promise is that you could
actually pass data back in so here's a
function where we will actually yield
out that argument that's passed in and
then come back in and store something
into a constant so we'll pass in a
originally we will go ahead and will
yield a and then when we come back again
we'll actually store the next thing and
B and then finally we have a plus B and
so the way that works is like we call it
we'd get back that a then we call it
again we pass in the two and then
finally we get the get both of them
combined so we passed in something we
left the function we came back in with
more stuff we got stuff and so it's kind
of interesting because like sometimes we
saw with that like multiple callbacks
before like you need to like get some
information and do some more stuff like
this kind of interplay of like thank you
for some information let me give you
some and like we can like build more
complicated asynchronous flows is really
interesting so sometimes we need to wait
for a bit of information and now we have
the ability to pause functions and come
back to them later with more information
so hey to put stuff on the page I need
to fulfill this network request I have
to wait for that so why don't you let me
do something else like handle a click
event and when we get back to the
network we'll come back in and pick up
where we left off all right so you could
write some terrible code like this this
is using generators you can see I'm
making two API requests I have this like
request thing which is just by using it
Ajax function with the promise that I
made before and it's kicking off the
generator every time with the it next
and so I yield each time which is I
leave that function as I wait for the
network request to finish and every time
I get the next piece of data I can store
it a constant and move along and have to
do this like kind of interesting stuff
here where I've got the function main
like a messy programmer or something and
then I've got these yields in there they
seem interesting I've got this like part
right here where I'm kicking off the
generator again which has to kind of be
in a global scope which is gnarly
and then to kick off my entire program I
have to do this this is kind of gross it
works but it makes me feel bad inside
but interesting fact if you take
promises and then you match them with
you mixing with generators and then you
just throw in a bunch of syntactic sugar
to make believe you don't just see all
that code is just show you you know you
get a single wave that's all a single
wait is its promises and generators and
some black magic and a curtain so you
don't see any of the dark
that's actually going on in other things
so yeah we bring them together here we
can go and we can we have this code from
before and we just say hey this is an
async function and we replace those
yields with a wait all of that sadness
is gone error handling you get the try
cash that's in the language which is
fine and that again that Ajax function
is the same promise one that was based
on the callback one that we looked at
earlier in this talk right so you can do
a whole bunch of really cool stuff I
wanted to get both simultaneously I can
use promised at all in an async function
and await it because it's all promises
and all generators under the hood so
none of this is sorcery it's just
JavaScript which arguably is sorcery and
all the other like crazy things that
you've like read about in like
JavaScript legally or hacker news or
whatever is mostly some combination of
events promises and callbacks right and
so there are a lot of other interesting
patterns out there they're all based on
this and like once you have these
foundations like kind of like we've
wrapped your mind around them like I
think you're ready under like they're
it's not like oh this library I don't
know how it works like you now have like
all the foundational pieces in place so
yeah all that kind of fun stuff is based
on literally stuff that we just spent
the last 25 minutes and 30 seconds and
177 slides on so thank you very much
[Applause]